yes Richards gonna live this is the
story of a death row inmate who didn't
kill and who refuses to die three times
during 2015 he came within hours or even
minutes of being executed and each time
he survived yes and he pounded on the
window it's also my story of how and why
I befriended a man convicted of murder
and who asked me to witness his
execution Richard Glossip
is the dead man who keeps walking for me
the story began a year ago I was looking
for an interesting case to illustrate
the continuing debate over the death
penalty in the United States I found it
in Oklahoma which executes more people
per head of population than any other
state
the case involves a murder at this motel
on the outskirts of Oklahoma City in
January 1997 the body of a man was found
in room 102 of the downmarket
best budget in Barry van Reese was the
owner of the motel he'd been beaten to
death with a baseball bat
the man who killed him was a 19 year old
handyman who worked there when Justin
Sneed was picked up and questioned by
detectives he confessed to the killing
he initially said that the motive was
robbery but then he changed his story
and said that Richard Glossip had paid
him to carry out the murder gossip was
the motel manager he was in trouble
because Sneed told him he'd killed their
boss but Glossip seen here during his
police interrogation kept quiet about it
that made him an accessory after the
fact but he denied having anything to do
with murdering Vann trees for money but
with Sneed and gossip in custody
detectives were keen to charge both men
with murder
Sneed agreed to testify against Glossop
in return he would escape the death
penalty and be sent to prison for life
Richard Glossip was also offered a plea
deal if he said that he was guilty of
the crime then he too would simply go to
jail and he wouldn't face the death
sentence but Glossop was convicted and
condemned to die for 18 years home has
been in the City of McAllister as one of
49 death row inmates at Oklahoma State
Penitentiary Richard Glossip is the only
one of those men who didn't actually
kill anyone there was no forensic
evidence linking him to the murder of
Barry Van Treece and his conviction
relies almost entirely on the word of
the man who did kill him Justin Sneed is
now in a medium-security Jail and
sticking to his story mr. Glossop
cohorts me and and pleaded with me for
over three months in the numerous
amounts of money that he was offering me
kept changing up to that TV interview
had been recorded in November 2014 by
Fox 25 in Oklahoma the prison
authorities have banned Glossop from
doing any more he definitely believes in
his innocence I mean there's no sign
that you know whether or not you know
it's true or not I mean he's come to the
point where he definitely believes it
he's never been in trouble convicted on
the word of one guy been a model
prisoner by all accounts Kym Van Atta
lives in New York City and works in
child health care it's a world away from
Oklahoma's death row but 15 years ago a
friend asked him if he would become a
pen pal to a prisoner who shared his
taste in music man is unbelievably
decent I mean he just really is there's
nothing that suggests that he is guilty
too
the I tend to think that simplest is
usually the most accurate and the simple
motive here was a robbery gone bad as
the killer said at the beginning while I
was in his apartment Richard Glossip
called this was to be the first of many
conversations with him in the months
ahead three days before his execution
date and anti-death-penalty campaigners
had come to the Oklahoma State Capitol
to Lobby the governor among them one of
America's most famous opponents of
capital punishment i've accompanied six
human beings to execution richard would
be the seventh man that i would be with
sister Helen Prejean spoke about working
with death row prisoners had been turned
into an oscar-winning movie it's not
just the one except the death penalty
comfort him as he dies it's you got to
resist things that are wrong the
governor of Oklahoma has the power to
grant a 60-day stay of execution but
Mary Fallon was refusing to intervene
and has refused to be interviewed about
this case
so on the eve of his execution family
and friends turned up at the jail for
what was supposed to be their final
visit among them a daughter he hadn't
seen for 18 years more than four people
in but there was still a good chance the
execution would be called off the US
Supreme Court had agreed to consider
evidence about one of the drugs used in
the lethal injection process my dazzling
is an anesthetic used to sedate the
prisoner before two more drugs paralyze
and then kill but critics say it's
inadequate you've got inmates who are
conscious now you've got inmates who are
gasping one of the descriptions was that
the inmate was flopping around like a
fish against the restraints that's
someone who is clearly experiencing high
levels of pain my dazzling was used
because states could no longer get hold
of their first choice pentobarbital its
manufacturer the Danish company lund
Beck stopped supplying it when they
discovered it was being used in
executions we have never been providing
pentobarbital by purpose for prison so
of course it was quite a shock we are a
company conducting research to save
people lives with severe brain diseases
so this was from our view the complete
opposite but public opinion in Oklahoma
was still in favor of capital punishment
and some of its leaders aren't too fussy
about how its carried out I support the
lethal injection I support hanging I
support you know whatever it takes if
the state deems is necessary to effect
that death and if it got to a point
where we didn't have the technological
advancements to have lethal injections
and I would support hanging or beheading
or whatever it would take to make sure
that that person in the end meets his
justice it was a celebration it was a
party wasn't it but with the supreme
court looking at lethal injection a stay
of execution was agreed the news came
through while gossips family and friends
were with him
such a struggling and I'm not gonna get
what you don't care about I just I'm
just very very happy right now this is a
family prepaid call from the
postponement meant I now had time to set
up a prison phone account so he could
ring me direct we talked about his close
call with the death chamber we'll hear
argument first this morning in case 1479
fifty-five Glossop versus gross just
comment mr. Chief Justice and may it
please the court the United States
Supreme Court is made up of nine
justices four liberals for conservatives
and one who's harder to pin a label on
Richard gossips lawyers needed to get
the backing of five of them so Richard
blossoms cases made it to the US Supreme
Court who's named is on the document for
today listing his case but the case was
nothing to do with his personal guilt or
innocence this was all about trying to
prove that my dazzling the drug used as
an anesthetic is not suitable
one of the justices certainly thought so
suppose that we said we're going to
bring you with mistake but before we do
we're going to use an anesthetic of
completely unknown properties and
unknown effects maybe you won't feel it
maybe you will we just can't tell and
and you think that that would be okay
but outside Oklahoma's attorney general
was defending his state's record on how
would put prisoners to death here the
state of Oklahoma
since the late 1970s actually was the
state that birthed and gave life to the
lethal injection process it's the most
humane way to carry out capital
punishment the verdict was announced
three months later I was reporting in
Tunisia when Richard called with his
reaction to the news that he'd lost his
appeal five four within a few days a new
date was set for his execution he was
now due to die on September the 16th
you
two weeks before Richard Glossip was due
to be put to death
and I was on my way to see him for the
first time hours of phone calls are no
substitute for meeting with him in
person he's never seen my face he
doesn't know what I looked like even and
yet this is a man who I have developed a
relationship with to the point where he
is comfortable having me
as one of a handful of witnesses on his
side to witness his execution so I feel
a sense of responsibility that I really
do not just need to get to know him but
he needs to get to know me I expected
him to be depressed but instead he was
laughing and joking and exuberant
because his case was at last attracting
a lot of publicity this was one of the
reasons the partnership of sister Helen
Prejean and Susan Sarandon here they are
next to each other during a scene from
dead man walking because of their
friendship the actress had agreed to
talk to Sky News about the death penalty
and about Richard Glossip
he's a perfect example of what's wrong
with the death penalty and so of course
I'm hoping that some kind of exposure
will give him the opportunity to maybe
you know get his sentence at least
commuted because he's clearly innocent
but it was her comment about Mary Fallon
which created headlines in America the
governor of Oklahoma is just a horrible
person and a woman so it's even more
discouraging her news making apology the
publicity led to new witnesses coming
forward Glossop's lawyer said they
showed Justin Snead had lied to save his
own skin but among those listening to
the news conference was the district
attorney who is angry that the case was
now playing out in the media at the end
of the day what does it matter to the
state whether
Richard Glossip is executed in two days
time around 62 it wasn't us the
Venturi's family about
the continuous delays the constant
delays don't you talk about that we work
in the rule of law here okay and let me
tell you what personally it really
wouldn't matter to me if I had that much
that much of a question about mr.
Glossop's bill but I do not sir and at
some point this process has to stop
especially when the defense team is
playing games with the process and with
you giving you evidence of new
information a few hours later the new
evidence was handed over to the
governor's spokesman but it was already
obvious she'd made up her mind and
unless a court rules to stop the
execution or delay it but the execution
will move forward and the governor and
you will rest easy with your decision I
have looked at the evidence and I think
Richard gossips guilty these are from
January till now well until but
thousands of people have written letters
or posted messages of support on his
website after he reads them and tries to
reply to as many as possible they're
passed on to his family for safekeeping
does it bring any comfort seeing all
these letters and seeing these people
whoo-hoo yes it does it means that we're
being heard and people are seeing for
themselves that he's innocent and this
is helping him to have his positive
outlook every day knowing that people do
care if the worst comes to the worst and
September the 16th comes around and the
governor hasn't intervened and no new
evidence is emerged what do you do what
are you doing today just pray that it's
quick and just peaceful you're gonna go
to sleep
you're gonna start snoring and then
you're gonna pass away quietly and
that's what Randall workman would tell
those about to die as a former warden at
Oklahoma State Penitentiary he's
overseen 32 executions I can't remember
the number of times that I seen victims
families that was hostile about that I
didn't get what I wanted from it I
didn't see what I wanted to see I didn't
I didn't get satisfaction
all they did is went to sleep they
wanted to see some pain he did were you
never worried that mistakes could be
made and that's an innocent man was
being executed I hear the stories and I
see the shows were the DNA has proven
that a person was wrongfully committed
can I say it's possible yes yes I can
say that it's possible do I personally
feel like that I've executed somebody
that is innocent I'd say it's not for me
to say the courts had decided another
rally by Glossop supporters and
anti-death-penalty campaigners did
nothing to change the governor's mind on
the eve of his scheduled execution Mary
Fallon rejected calls for her to
intervene I didn't know whether this
would be the last time I spoke to
Richard I was a reporter struggling with
the concept of impartiality I've met him
and I believe his story I don't think
there's enough evidence to prove he is
guilty of murder and certainly not
enough to justify executing him
11:30 was when I and the other witnesses
had to report to the prison gates the
execution was due to happen at 3:00 one
of the officials who checked my ID told
me this is a horrible events but we're
going to make it as pleasant as possible
he promised coffee and cookies
but thirty minutes later we were back
outside the appeal court had intervened
the execution was delayed for two weeks
while judges looked at the new evidence
Richard was there and we said there's
been a stay and he became ecstatic
he said yes and he pounded on the window
he was just so happy had you given up
hope or did you still think that there
was a chance amidst the celebrations
expectations were rising for something
more than simply a temporary
postponement I don't think I'm gonna
have to come back except for his
exoneration because I think that's what
we're headed in a basement below the
appeal court is the archive department
where criminal case files are stored
transcripts of witnesses testimony of
experts and photos of the crime scene
but what convicted Richard Glossip was
the testimony of Justin's need gossips
lawyers have pointed to inconsistencies
in Sneed's version 2 of the appeal court
judges agreed that the evidence in the
case was deeply flawed and questionable
but they were outvoted 3 to 2 2 days
before the scheduled execution his
appeal was rejected the following day I
spoke to Richard just as he was being
served his final meal for the third time
in nine months
the next morning we were back at the
prison once again he was due to die at 3
p.m. as the minutes ticked away what
seemed like his last hope disappeared
word reached his family and supporters
that the US Supreme Court had rejected a
final appeal I think that's a pretty big
deal at 3 o'clock I was inside the
prison but still waiting to be taken
into the death chamber there was no
explanation for the delay nobody was
telling Richard Glossip anything either
some people wouldn't give me any answers
I think that was just as much talking
waiting for him to kill an innocent
person but outside news was spreading
quickly the execution had been called
off because of an astonishing blunder
Injection issued
something about the anonymous company
which supplies the lethal injection that
sent potassium acetate rather than
potassium chloride I just couldn't take
my eyes off the clock and between
quarter past 2:00 and 10 to 3:00 I was
feeling just sick at the idea that we
were just about to be taken to watch a
man die this had become such a
high-profile case that the authorities
did not dare proceed reporters crowded
round to hear from the man who should
have been dead by now
24 hours after trying to kill him
the prison staff now had a different
mission they're trying to keep him alive
the case has also prolonged the agony of
the family of the murder victim barry
van therese you want it to be over with
you want this part to be finished you
want to be able to take a breath and to
carry on knowing that justice has been
served an inquiry into the mix-up
between potassium acetate and potassium
chloride means all executions in
Oklahoma are now on hold for at least
six months the prison admitted the wrong
drug had been used to kill another
inmate last January but his case didn't
attract as much publicity as Richard
Glossip soon after that revelation the
prison warden Anita Trammell left her
post and took early retirement then a
few weeks later Robert Paton the head of
the entire Oklahoma prison system also
decided to quit his job
this extraordinary case has provided
fresh ammunition for those fighting to
abolish the death penalty
many people believe it's only a matter
of time before the balance of opinion at
the Supreme Court tilts in favor of
abolition we don't yet know whether
Richard Bossip will live to see that day
his execution may be on hold but the
state of Oklahoma still wants to kill
him maybe tremendous difference in my
life and great gratitude